FAREED ZAKARIA: The World
Economic Forum in Davos
is usually fixated
on the future.
Most years, the attendees
are dazzled by some country,
company, or technology promising
to burst forward, force change,
dominate the next decade.
This year, the focus was not
on the future, but the past.
People delve back into
history to debate what caused
Russia's invasion of Ukraine.
The Swedish finance
minister explained
why his country,
which hasn't been
at war since the
Napoleonic wars,
was breaking its 200-year
tradition of neutrality
with his bid to join NATO.
The Finnish foreign minister
recalled Finland's resistance
to Moscow's aggression in the
Winter War of 1939 and 1940.
In past years at Davos,
companies took storefronts
and plastered them
with jubilant signs,
cheering on dynamism,
acceleration, and disruption.
This time, there were far
fewer placards and slogans,
some of them meekly
promising sustainability
or progress on climate change.
The one genuinely
cheerful sign I saw
said, "Will the Saudi
GDP now be fueled
by YOLO, FOMO, and WYWH?"
With oil at over $100 a
barrel, the Saudi regime
has much to be excited about.
The storefront that
dominated detention
was one that used to be booked
for years by Russians who
hosted lavish cocktail
parties and caviar
tastings there with the
country's moneyed elite.
Now, it has a sign in the window
that reads in small cleartype
"This used to be the
Russian house in Davos.
Now, it's the Russian war
crimes house in Davos."
Sponsored by the Ukrainian
businessman Viktor Pinchuk,
the rooms are filled
with striking images
and stories of Russia's
barbaric actions
in its campaign against Ukraine.
Ukraine dominated
Davos this year,
and most people I
spoke to were quite
unsure how this war would end.
That played into a larger sense
of uncertainty about the world
that we are heading into.
A world of multiplying risks.
Tharman Shanmugaratnam,
Singapore's senior minister,
said to me, "We know the risks
that are out there are large.
They're not about black swan
events, coming out of the blue.
A pandemic was predicted.
Russia's invasion was
a known possibility.
Another pandemic or more
frequent climate crises--
these are not just
possible, but likely.
We can't keep expecting
and planning for a return
to calm, untroubled times."
A former central
banker told me that
economic policymakers
felt that they
were in uncharted territory.
"The old model-- where inflation
moves up ever so slightly,
and then you raised rates a tiny
bit and all was well-- that's
dead.
We're in a new world, and
we're all just experimenting."
There is a broader foreboding, a
sense that the era we have just
lived through, the three
decades since 1990,
may have been an unusual,
perhaps, even unique
one in which great
power politics
and geopolitical tensions that
normally dominate and define
international life were absent.
The giddy trends
of recent times--
globalization, the
information revolution,
even democratization--
were trends
built on an edifice of power,
America's superpower status.
But that strength
has been waning
for some years, caused by Iraq,
the global financial crisis,
COVID.
Now, it is being
challenged-- first
by China, and then Russia.
In all this gloom, there's
one distinctly hopeful sign.
Europe is acting with a greater
sense of unity and purpose
than I've ever seen before.
Every European
leader I spoke with
believe that Russia's aggression
has sparked a revolution
of sorts across the continent.
The EU has shown remarkable
unity on sanctions,
and is slowly but
steadily coming
together on energy policy.
These successes could
evolve into greater
coordination on foreign,
and even defense policy.
Europeans have realized
at a fundamental level
that they were taking peace
and stability for granted.
That it might now have to
be created and sustained
by hard work and
commitment, in part,
by building hard power of
their own and deploying
it strategically.
There are serious
debates about ending
the slow, consensual process
of EU decision making
that allows one country like
Hungary to veto its efforts.
The most lasting
legacy of this crisis
could be a new role
for Europe as a more
purposeful, strategic
actor on the world stage.
But for that to happen,
this experience in uniting
against Russia has to work.
Only success can
breed more success.
Failure will doom
this experiment.
The founding fathers
of the European Union,
like Robert Schuman and Jean
Monnet, were steeped in history
and determined to
ensure that war did
not break out again in Europe.
Today's statesmen need to infuse
their day to day decisions
with a similar sense of history.
50 years from now, no one will
remember whether growth slowed
on the continent for a
couple of quarters in 2022
or if Brussels had to pay extra
for natural gas from the US.
What they will recall is
the answer to one question.
Who won the war in Ukraine?
Putin or the West.